I think I have a version of me that
lives on stage but I'm not a character
I'm fairly honest yeah I think that that
that is really what's kept me out of the
big time for for a long time is that
like yeah I'm not an arena act but if
you kind of lock into what I'm doing you
know there's certain people I usually
say I don't have a demographic I have a
disposition
it feels very accurate yeah I think
these are most of the notes for the new
special is there a filing process for
this or is it just you just one on top
of the other no this is like you know
there's stacks of this type of stuff
like this is like I'm trying to get it
down to an hour and I'm writing it on
you know the ham yard Hotel stationary
in London like it's like the week before
I got to do an hour I'm like all right
you know so it's a nice hotel though but
like these are things I would write down
like it just says we are wired for
duplicity our parents aren't who we
think they are like I don't know what
that means to you but it gets a good
laugh and there's a truth to it yeah
right and then I just say gaslighting is
parenting you know so my kids would
agree with that right this one says when
I hate myself I hate everyone who has
ever liked me
so you know some of it makes it in some
of it doesn't but it's all here were you
even in the beginning as personal on
stage not really I no I mean but oddly I
always thought like like I started
watching myself a few years ago uh like
from 89 like do an evening at The Improv
and stuff
and I've watched them and I'm like you
know the jokes are okay but I am me but
you know no I'm not a grounded me you
know I'm not you know someone who has
control of my craft I'm not somebody
who's comfortable up there yeah yeah I
was terrified all the time I I tell
people that for however long it takes
about 80 of your energy goes into
pretending you're not afraid that for me
went on for years so how did you keep
going on because I'm a compulsive weirdo
I felt like I was chosen to do this I
don't I don't know why because there was
never a plan B when I got out here I was
not emotionally stable I had no sense of
what it was like to be a grown-up you
know I was sleeping on the floor you
just it was all I wanted to do do you
feel like even with all the other things
you do right you're a stand-up comic at
heart that's all man you know when I
started doing the podcast because you
know people were like
yeah they didn't know me as a comic
because I wasn't anybody you know I've
been you know plugging away for 20 30
years as you know I did TV spots and
stuff I couldn't sell tickets you know
Comics knew me a few people knew me but
I was not a comedy Star right so by the
time I started the podcast which was a
Hail Mary pass you know I got a big
audience and I'm telling them I'm doing
stand-up and they'd start coming to
these shows thinking we should support
Mark like I know how to do this you know
I'm glad you liked the interview show
but I've been doing this my whole life
you know uh so that was sort of an
interesting adjustment and a weird thing
to accept that my fame yeah or my you
know the skill set that really launched
me yeah was what you do yeah right so
and and there was a long time where like
I really thought you know to make sure
that I had a monologue in in the in the
podcast and it took me a long time to
accept
that you know it's okay to be doing that
you know you know whether people saw me
as a comic or not I was good at this
other thing yeah and you know and
something you know some Cosmic timing
on the map what did that do with your
head in terms of how you saw yourself
it was it was tricky because I didn't I
I didn't want to ever let go of being
you know recognized as a comedian so it
was weird because you know most of the
shows at the beginning were Comics it
was really a comic-centric show and it
was me basically trying to you know
apologize for being you know a bitter
you know Monster to certain people okay
I I think uh you know there were two
things happening in the first hundred or
so episodes it was me having you know
celebrities in to talk about my problems
and uh and me apologizing to people for
things that I was carrying but they
usually didn't even remember yeah that's
how that's how I developed my style yeah
yeah were you working something out
there or I mean as you said it's a Hail
Mary pass obviously job-wise but yeah
but there was no money in it but it was
just I needed to keep doing something
because I was looking down the sort of
the tunnel of being a a kind of a you
know B room headliner or you know a
headliner that didn't have a following
and that's a hard life and it's a sad
life and it's a life I know I know a lot
of people that live that life and you
know I I'd like to think that I I you
know it was very dark time you know I I
didn't really want to live that life and
I and I'm not sure I wanted to I could
have dealt with it but sadly I probably
would have and I'm just grateful that it
changed I want to talk about about the
HBO special because I mean you
there are two particular areas you deal
with that are that are
um that are very personal the first is
your dad yeah who you've talked about in
the past
and you're in a really unusual spot
there because your dad has dementia yeah
and you've had a really complicated
relationship with him yeah
how has that changed your relationship
well you know the funny thing about my
dad you know is like it's complicated to
the degree you know at some point
you know I had the upper hand in a way
you know my dad is kind of a uh he was
always kind of a very self-centered you
know erratic guy you know a little
bipolar and you know just you know uh
not intimidating but you know a little
scary sometimes but at some point you
know I stopped taking it yeah and a lot
of it had to do with comedy is that like
my father
like I tell a story about how even when
I was in high school and he was
depressed when he was he had paralyzing
depression you know my mother would say
you know why don't you go and make your
father laugh you're the only one that
can you know so it's like oh tough crowd
I tell you yeah but but that Dynamic
never went away I can really bust on my
dad to his face in a very brutal way and
he just kills him he loves it he loves
it but yeah it's difficult and it's sad
and you know and I think that I'm not
unlike
other stand-ups or people in general
you know I can find a way to talk about
it that you know is funny and
heartbreaking but you you know you you
do keep a certain you
comedy disarms things and it's it
protects you there's a defensiveness
involved in it and it you know and it I
think it helps me survive and I and you
know I can let feelings in you know uh
and and I and I do and and I know where
this is leading uh but like
it's okay right now yeah
to what degree is making comedy out of
it therapeutic I think it's therapeutic
but there's also an edge of Cruelty to
it so that's something you have to
accept it's like you know this stuff is
you know it feels a little wrong to be
talking about it like I'm talking about
it but the truth of the matter is like
75 of the people in this country are
going to deal with this and and if you
don't have some operating sense of humor
uh to sort of counter the the horror of
it uh it's going to be a difficult run
so I want to talk about Lynn because
that
you've been through a whole process
in with that
that started right after she died yeah
when you when you immediately went onto
a podcast
and and now you're you're taking to the
point of putting that in your comedy
and you you make
you make light of just that process
itself which is really interesting of
tragedy and grief and losing somebody
yeah I'm just wondering how you how you
got how you get to that point
in terms of in terms of putting in
material and deciding that you can you
can be funny about it that was always
part of what I did as a comic right and
as I'm talking new I start to realize
that this other stuff the personal stuff
is really the same that I'm going you
know to a darker place and I'm taking
certain chances emotional chances and
also risks around how I'm framing things
that seem either taboo or or not talked
about you know talking about grief it's
just something people don't do because
it's frightening and they don't there's
a lot of reasons it's complicated and
you know look man I
you know it was devastating and I'd
never experienced anything that you know
like in dealing with my father like her
death tragically and quickly and
unexplainably
uh you know just it just shattered you
know everything uh in me emotionally
yeah like any sort of control you think
you have over life any sort of plans you
think you have for the future you know
anything yeah all those things that's
sort of like nah that won't happen yeah
and
and dealing with those feelings and
choosing to do the podcast two days
after she she passed away it's only
because that's what we did yeah is that
I wasn't looking for anything and I
really have thought this through I
thought that if I go on the mics in this
state you know because people knew she
passed yes that it would speak to
something that's never spoken to those
feelings that I was having are usually
had alone or with with you know uh with
you know close family or whatever you
could have decided though not not to do
it yeah my producer was like we don't
have to ever do a podcast again yeah
it's up to you yeah but I thought
it would help people to go on in that
state and it was awful and I haven't
listened to it
do you think you would
uh
it's sad man it was sad you know and
that's the thing is like you know if I
if I talk about it for a while you know
it it's right there you know grief is
like yeah like there's a while there
where you can't control it and you're
just like you know crying and and
and uh you you just can't stop it and
you don't even understand it you don't
even know what you're feeling but it's
like it's like happening well most of
all you just need to feel it yeah but
but there's like you're going to it's
like there's no need involved yeah
because like my my instinct would be
like I gotta stop this yeah how am I
gonna you know but there's no stopping
it and it's always sort of right there
uh you know if I talk about it it's just
so awful
um but in terms of talking about it
comedically is that I I knew it would
evolve it was just sad sometimes and I
would cry on stage yeah and I didn't
know how to get out of it but because of
how I told you I write yeah I knew
eventually I would have to make it funny
you know because crying's not that
entertaining
so so it kind of evolved like that
and um I just thought my belief was
there's a couple things happening was
that like I figured that everyone knew
that I'd experienced this wasp because
it was a public thing yeah and and I
there was one thing I didn't want and I
think and I don't know that I've ever
thought about this until now which is
how I am it happens out loud was that I
didn't want to be seen as a victim
because you know she was the victim so I
didn't want people to feel sorry for me
so my way of dealing with that was you
know is to be funny but but not to avoid
it yeah right interesting it is kind of
interesting I don't know if I ever
really thought of that before
do you think you talked about it because
you felt like you kind of had to talk
about it apparently yeah yeah because
people are used to you talking about
your life right and but also I had to
respect her why was that relationship so
special to you because you said you
never felt anything like that before the
reason was so powerful is like I was
terrified to give into it why
I don't I don't know it's just like
because I'm emotionally not good not
right but to answer your question you
know there's just nobody really like
that person nobody like Lynn Shelton and
she
she she actually uh you know
you know she just made me uh believe in
myself yeah
that's a big thing
for me it is
how are you now
um
I mean I'm okay because I don't really
you know let myself go where I just went
you know 30 seconds ago
I don't mind opening up like totally up
there I I more more so than in my life
why is that do you think
because in some ways it's less risky you
need it probably and I've never been
happier doing it and I don't think I've
ever been better doing it so there's a
part of me that's sort of like you know
I think I'm finally enjoying this